the world
say hi to Harriet Demi lavato introduced
the world to her new cat just last month
but she had to return it shortly after
you have a new cat you have Batman your
adorable dog she like couldn't keep the
cat I had to give it back the next day
because I'm allergic
yeah I know I thought I wouldn't because
it doesn't have any hair but Harriet was
the best name ever I know wasn't it Demi
did share this pic when she first got
her new pet but said she was keeping it
anyways so while she's one cat down or
her pup Batman will be hitting the road
with her Nick Jonas this summer on the
future now tour
Fatman blow on the road with you he will
demi g's the tour and confirmed a new
album at Sunday's Billboard Music Award
I think when my fans can expect
obviously music but new music and you
know a great show I think we want it to
be an experience rather than just a
concert so down to the smell of the
arena we want to make it incredible for
our Vince are you tweeting that you
actually just wrote a new song or and
recorded it what does it sound like can
you tease it at all um I would love to
but I kind of want to keep people
guessing a new album are you working on
the follow-up